Brad Pitt who made some shocking
confessions apparently Brad isn't much
of a crier
did you know you broke the internet
mistake missteps and choices I've made
that I'm not proud of
that's how Brad now frames some of the
past including his drinking which led
Angelina to file for divorce in 2016
Pitt says he's still wrestling with
blame calling it struggle with alcohol a
quote disservice to myself as an escape
the reflective almost 56 year old tells
all to former co-star Anthony Hopkins
for Interview magazine including that
he's now forgetting himself for mistakes
because he lets you some wisdom
Brad also credits his six kids with
Angie for helping him connect to his
emotions quote I hadn't cried in like 20
years now I find myself at this latter
stage much more moved as for Brad's
x-gen her friends giving gas Jimmy
Kimmel is spilling all about their
star-studded dinner someone decided to
start serving all the same stuff at
friendsgiving
that you eat on Thanksgiving this upsets
me so I said in I thought a nice way I
know you love Mexico gracias giving
could be a nice thing
Jen made me enchiladas and not just
enchiladas but
edge' lavas Jen also celebrated with
Courtney Cox and now Netflix has just
posted New Year's Eve is the final date
to stream friends before it heads to HBO
max in May but
[Music]